[Music]
i guess there's a certain part of me
that's always thought that computer
parts look like cities
my name is zaid mink i'm an 18 year old
artist from zimbabwe
i grew up in a family of
nine people
my parents had a repurposing attitude
towards most things how can we use the
rubbish to make something else
so i just make
my artwork out of the things that i find
and the things that i collect
[Music]
i grew up in harare the capital city of
zimbabwe and i really like it there
but we do have quite a few challenges
like political unrest and economic
challenges
there's also e-waste dumping that has
affected many of the poorer areas around
the city
[Music]
this project that i'm working on is a
collaboration with hpe to make an area
of westminster done in recycled
electronics
i think what i'm doing on a small scale
is basically what they doing on a large
scale in a slightly different way
the parts for this project were from
hpe's facility
it was quite different compared to what
happened for my first project
with that one i had to go around asking
friends and family and trying to
scavenge things from side of the road
when planning for this project i used a
lot of online resources to calculate
what area i want to do
it was also quite helpful to see things
in person it puts things in perspective
quite nicely
from there i sketch out the layout of
the city and i just start building the
individual buildings one by one
i think in a perfect tool there wouldn't
be
such a thing as waste everything would
be
reused and repurposed for something else
there are about 50 million tons of
e-waste generated on an annual basis and
substances that go into the products
have impacts to soil water human health
we can't just take make dispose anymore
we need to really think about how we
responsibly design manufacture and
dispose of the products or potentially
reuse them at their end of life
the circular economy is a shift from the
traditional linear economy into a model
where it's regenerative in nature
one of the most exciting aspects of our
environmental program are our technology
renewal centers
of the material that comes in the door
over 89 is actually refurbished
remarketed and sold to new customers the
remaining portion is recycled in a
responsible way to have real impact at
scale
in the future if companies embrace the
idea of the circular economy e-waste
might not be an issue
and my artwork might be seen as a sort
of
weird historical artifact from a time
when we didn't know any better
[Music]
you